[Music]
he is investors earning call released a
whole bunch of interesting tidbits about
their upcoming games for example
Bioware's new IP is gonna launch before
April 2018 as a new Need for Speed on
the horizon and they're not making scape
ball boo but they did confirm the
existence of FIFA 18 and that it'll
bring with it season 2 of the story mode
the journey I'm Lucy and welcome to your
referee game spot news update EA CEO
Andrew Wilson said FIFA 18 will build on
the foundation we created with story
mode this year bringing players back to
the journey with season 2 featuring new
characters and new storylines our
development team in Vancouver is
delivering deeply innovative new
experiences across this year's game
including an Ultimate Team and creating
the most emotionally immersive and
connected FIFA we have ever produced
we also noted that more than 10 million
fans have played the journey and
ultimate team players are up nearly 10
percent year-on-year journey was a
story-driven adventure introduced in 417
that sees you follow a young footballer
called Alex hunter it featured dedicated
characters cutscenes and appearances
from real-life players and managers for
all the news from EAS call make sure to
check out our roundup on GameSpot calm
what improvements and new features do
you want to see MV for 18 be sure to let
us know in the comments below or come
find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games for marnier and FIFA make sure to
LIKE this video and subscribe to
GameSpot on YouTube
you
[Music]